evening in an industry full of unsung
professionals it is perhaps the
publicist who is rarely heard from so
far as the public knows and yet speaks
so loudly for a production and its
filmmakers and few publicists in show
business history have had such a
resounding voice as that of Marvin levy
to talk with Marvin one on one which
thank God I've had the experience of
because he's saved me and made me
somehow represent myself or my film well
thank God he is a gentle and reserved
man who also has ideas extraordinary
stories and the sharpest sense of humor
sparking out of him at a rapid pace to
know of Marvin's work especially on the
films of Stephens as we've seen is to
recognize a voice that has shouted
around the world about the movie magic
in store for audiences once a new Steven
Spielberg film has opened Marvin has
worked with Steven as you saw since 1977
on Close Encounters and he's been a
deeply respected visionary for decades
setting the tone and talk for films that
would capture the public imagination and
heart from et The Back to the Future
trilogy Lincoln and Schindler's List and
a beloved franchise I'm particularly
fond of the worlds of Jurassic Park
these okay yes let's take a moment
everybody these films and so many more
as you saw from Gigi and Ben Hur - they
shoot horses don't they - American
Beauty the gladiator most recently with
the post he helped make these must-see
events even the greatest of filmmakers
can create works that as we know fail to
find their audiences if not for the
publicist that serve as the ones to say
to the world Hey look over here we've
got something extraordinarily special
that you'll not want to miss and that is
what Marvin has done for so long not
only as a means to a truly laudable
career but as a personal mission
in his always humble fashion marvin
underplay is a very complex job by
stating it's all about the eyeballs it's
about getting people to see a film
whether it's in seats in a theater or
watching sitting on a sofa at home film
after film year after year decade after
decade
Marvin levy has done his job and beyond
measure in getting eyes on screens and
viewers and seats for films big and
small he's been an integral and
unflappable part of bringing the dreams
of creative visionaries into the lives
of generations of movie lovers he is
also the best person to go through a
hurricane with but don't get any ideas
that I have had that experience it is my
sincere honor to pay tribute to a man to
stand here tonight with all of you and
along with Carol his extraordinary
partner who after defining his craft for
so many years and helping us all find
movies that would change our lives and
inspire us I have the privilege of
honoring someone who still loves to go
into work every day with zero plan of
ever retiring Marvin a heartfelt
thank-you from the Academy for all you
have done in your life for cinema I
would now like to invite you to get up
here and get your Academy Award your
Oscar congratulations